>> John: WE WILL KEEP
FOLLOWING THIS ONE.
>> Gillian: STATES ARE
BEGINNING TO ROLL BACK SOME
CORONAVIRUS RESTRICTIONS, PEOPLE
ARE SURPRISED TO LEARN THE CDC
GUIDELINES FOR SUMMER CAMP WILL
BE VERY STRICT THIS YEAR.
IT INCLUDES MASKS INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS AS WELL AS SOCIAL
DISTANCING FOR THE KIDS,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI SAYS THERE
COULD BE SOME CHANGES.
LISTEN.
>> I WOULDN’T CALL THEM
EXCESSIVE.
THEY WILL CONTINUALLY REEVALUATE
THAT.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT LOOKS A BIT STRICT, BUT
STRINGENT.
>> DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US NOW.
LET’S PULL UP SOME OF THE
GUIDELINES SO WE CAN GET ON THE
SAME PAGE HERE.
MASKS AT ALL TIMES UNLESS EATING
OR SWIMMING, NO CLOSE CONTACT
SPORTS, CAMPERS HAVE TO STAY
THREE OR 6 FEET APART, THEY HAVE
TO REMAIN DISTANCED AND TWO
LAYERS OF MASKS WHEN SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THE FIRST QUESTION HERE.
WHAT DATA IS BEHIND THESE
GUIDELINES.
>> THIS IS VERY ANTIQUATED.
IT’S NOT BASED ON CURRENT
SCIENCE.
I AM WORRIED THAT WITH THESE
GUIDELINES, I ALWAYS SAY WHILE
THEY’RE JUST GUIDELINES, IF
THESE GUIDELINES REMAIN IN PLACE
THEN THERE IS POTENTIAL LEGAL
PROBLEMS IF THEY DON’T FOLLOW
THEM.
WE KNOW FROM THE PANDEMIC THAT
COVID-19, THE VIRUS IS NOT
SPREADING ON SURFACES, VERY
UNUSUAL.
>> Gillian: NO ONE ASKS LIKE
IT.
EVERY TIME I GO INTO A STORE
PEOPLE ARE PUMPING ME WITH HAND
SANITIZER.
I WANT TO TELL THEM, IT’S ALL UP
UP.
>> I DON’T MIND THE HAND
SANITIZER BECAUSE YOU CAN TOUCH
SOMETHING AND GET IT ON YOUR
FACE, I’M OKAY WITH THAT, BUT
THE SURFACES ARE NOW WHERE IT’S
TRANSLATED AND IT’S CLEARLY A
RESPIRATORY VIRUS AND HERE’S THE
OTHER PART, MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE S SHOWN THAT IT’S NOT
TRANSMITTED OUTDOORS EXCEPT
RARELY, A STUDY IN IRELAND
SHOWED LESS THAN 100 CASES WERE
OUTDOORS, JAPAN, THE CDC HAS ALL
OF THIS SHOWING IT’S NOT
SPREADING OUTDOORS.
YOU WANT TO PUT A MASK ON A
2-YEAR-OLD, WHEN LESS THAN 300
YOUNG CHILDREN HAVE DIED OF
COVID OVER THE ENTIRE PANDEMIC.
WHAT IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH COST
OF TRYING TO DO THIS, TRYING TO
SUPERIMPOSE MASKS OR DOING
SPORTS OUTSIDE.
I WAS HAPPY TO SEE YOU DON’T
HAVE TO WORRY A MASK WHEN YOU
ARE SWIMMING.
>> Gillian: I’M LAUGHING
BECAUSE, SOME OF THIS STUFF IS
SO OBVIOUSLY COUNTERINTUITIVE
AND DANGEROUS THAT IT’S HARD TO
HAVE ANY RESPONSE.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
>> WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO AVOID
IS WHAT WE SAW IN OUTBREAKS LAST
SUMMER.
IF YOU HAVE 510-YEAR-OLDS WHO
ARE ON THE SOCCER FIELD IN FRONT
OF THE SAME SOCCER BALL, WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THERE IS
NOT HEAVY BREATHING WITH FIVE
KIDS AROUND.
>> DR. SIEGEL, THIS SUMMER AIN’T
LAST SUMMER, WE ARE DOING PRETTY
WELL.
DOWN 16% OVER THE LAST WEEK, FOR
STATES SAW AN UPTICK IN CASES.
2626 A MAJOR FALL.
>> THAT’S REALLY CORRECT AND I’M
GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP AND
CALIFORNIA HAS A POSITIVITY RATE
OF LESS THAN 1%.
1 OUT OF 100 PEOPLE WHO THINK
THEY HAVE COVID OR ACTUALLY THE
ONLY ONES WHO HAVE IT.
WE ARE GOING WAY DOWN.
AND I WANT TO ADD, YOU CAN TEXT
KIDS.
SHE’S LEAVING OUT WE NOW HAVE
RAPID TESTING.
YOU CAN’T PLAY SPORTS WITH MASKS
ON.
WHAT ABOUT RESPIRATORY RISKS?
A 4-YEAR-OLD AND HAVING THEM RUN
FULL TILT.
I BET THERE IS MORE OF A RISK OF
DOING THAT THAN HAVING THE
MASKS.
KIDS ARE NOT SPREADING THIS.
THEY’RE UNLIKELY TO SPREAD THIS.
COUNSELORS CAN GET VACCINATED.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A PERFECT